dépassé le chiffre des 410 mille
golfeurs licenciés c'est l'objectif
clairement affiché par la fédération
française avec l'organisation de la
première ryder cup sur le territoire
français la structure espère bénéficier
de ce coup de projecteur planétaire pour
attirer de nouveaux adeptes
on pense qu'après cette ryder cup
évidemment un plus grand nombre de
personnes auront eu un premier contact
avec le golf et on espère que bien sûr
ils vont se mettre à jouer au golf pour
créer une nouvelle génération de
passionnés la fédération française à
parier sur la jeunesse sans lançons dès
2015 à saint-quentin-en-yvelines mon
carnet de golf sur la ryder cup
un programme éducatif ludique pour les
cm1 et cm2 le succès qu'a remporté 7
cette opération a poussé l'éducation
nationale à étendre l'opération sur tout
le territoire
donc oui ça marche et ça continue à
marcher et ça va encore marcher la ryder
cup 2018 va également permettre au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
se faire un nom avec sa rénovation à 7,5
millions d'euros l'albatros est
considéré comme l'un des meilleurs
parcours au monde un standing qui lui
permettra d'organiser de nouvelles
compétitions internationales dans le
futur nous voulons poursuivre cette
politique d'accueil de grands événements
pour montrer et concrétisait toujours ce
savoir faire français et que la ryder
cup nous a offert et pourquoi pas je dis
pas que nous ferons mais on pourra y
tenir
après la ryder cup à accueillir la salle
polyvalent féminin de la ryder cup
en attendant la solheim cup le golf
national accueillera en 2022 les
championnats du monde et en 2024 les
jeux olympiques
le golf à saint quentin en yvelines une
histoire d'amour qui devrait durer